Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
En 2014,
150 000 personnes ont participé
à une course à obstacles.
Qu'est-ce que c'est,
une course à obstacles ?
C'est une course
où on va parcourir
un parcours avec des obstacles.
C'est inspiré du parcours du
combattant, un exercice militaire.
C'est inspiré des acro-branches,
des parcours aventure.
Et ça s'inscrit dans une méta-tendance
autour de l'effort personnel
et du dépassement de soi.
Il y a environ deux ans,
j'étais posé dans mon canapé,
et je suis tombé sur un site
de course à obstacles,
embarqué par un copain.
J'ai regardé les images...
et je me suis dit :
« Ces gens-là sont des fous. »
Je n'avais pas tort.
Mais, cette folie,
tout cet ensemble de course d'obstacles
va bien au-delà de la discipline.
Et je ne suis pas là pour vous
faire la promotion de mon sport,
mais je suis là pour vous parler
de la course à obstacles
en tant qu'allégorie du quotidien.
La course à obstacles,
c'est une discipline de notre
temps, de notre époque,
et qui nous aide, chaque jour,
à nous sentir plus vivants.
Dans la vie de tous les jours,
dans notre quotidien,
nous rencontrons des obstacles.
Ceux-ci sont physiques -
« Demain, je vais aller aider
un copain à déménager » -
ou psychologiques, mentaux.
Cela peut être les choix
de l'éducation pour son enfant.
Cela peut être également
des difficultés dans son travail,
des difficultés dans sa vie personnelle.
Et, face à tous ces obstacles,
nous avons besoin de nous dépasser.
Nous avons besoin de faire face.
Nous avons besoin de capacités,
parfois physiques, souvent mentales.
Et nous avons besoin de ressources.
Dans une course à obstacles,
nous allons rencontrer
volontairement des obstacles.
Ceux-ci sont physiques,
comme on peut le voir
avec cette épreuve du filet,
mais ceux-ci peuvent
également être mentaux :
il va nous falloir de la ténacité ;
il va falloir vaincre nos peurs ;
il va falloir nous dépasser.
Quand on parle de la course à obstacles,
on parle souvent d'un sport extrême,
d'un sport fait pour ceux qui veulent
aller plus loin, toucher leurs limites,
un sport, donc, de fous.
Ce n'est pas seulement ça.
Nous allons voir que la course
et dans la course à obstacles,
chacun a ses propres limites.
Certains événements vont
nous pousser à nous dépasser
en nous amusant,
en nous déguisant, pour le fun,
sur des petites distances.
D'autres vont arriver à se dépasser
avec des épreuves
plus longues, plus dures, plus extrêmes.
Certains vont même avoir besoin
d'aller chercher la performance,
chercher la compétition.
Et la première leçon
de la course à obstacles,
ce qu'elle nous apprend
dans la vie de tous les jours,
c'est que les limites que nous avons
sont propres à chaque personne,
et que nous avons besoin
de définir nos limites.
Et en allant vers ses propres limites,
en les dépassant que ce soit
physiquement ou mentalement,
on va se rendre plus fort,
et on va ainsi devenir plus vivant.
La course à obstacles
ressemble un sport individuel.
La vie de tous les jours
est un sport individuel.
On est seul avec les autres.
Sartre parlait même d'enfer des autres.
Mais, sans les autres, on n'est rien.
Face aux obstacles, on n'est rien.
Certaines courses
proposent des obstacles
qui sont infranchissables seul.
Sans aide, sans solidarité,
personne ne peut nous aider,
et surtout on ne peut pas passer
et on est forcé à l'abandon.
Pour aller plus loin dans la vie
comme dans la course à obstacles,
on a besoin de s'entraider.
On a besoin de faire avec ceux
qui participent avec nous.
Et la grande leçon,
c'est également que,
lorsque l'on court, lorsque l'on parcourt,
on ne sait pas qui va être à notre rythme,
on ne connaît pas les personnes.
Une personne que l'on
double, on va se dire :
« Je suis plus rapide qu'elle,
tant mieux ! », en fait, non.
Je vais avoir besoin d'elle pour m'aider.
Et cela nous aide également
à vaincre tous les préjugés.
On ne choisit pas qui on va aider,
ni qui va nous aider,
et on ne choisit pas qui peut
nous aider à passer cela.
Cette notion de respect,
cette notion d'humilité, d'entraide,
nous aident dans la vie de tous les jours
et sont une excellente leçon
pour notre quotidien.
Au-delà de ça -
et c'est souvent ce que l'on retient
des courses à obstacles -
il faut être quelqu'un de complet
pour finir une course.
On voit souvent beaucoup de coureurs
qui s'entraînent dans
des salles de musculation,
qui ont énormément de muscles,
qui vont être capables de monter
à la corde en trois secondes,
mais qui vont s'écrouler sur la distance.
À côté de ça, on va voir des gens
qui sont habitués des marathons,
et qui vont ramer sur les obstacles.
Face à une course et aux obstacles,
on a tous nos points forts,
et nos points faibles.
Et nous avons besoin
d'être des gens complets.
Cela va nous demander,
non seulement de la force et de
l'endurance comme on l'imagine,
mais également de l'agilité pour passer
des obstacles comme des poutres,
du dynamisme pour passer des obstacles
qui s'appellent les « monkey bars »,
ou encore des capacités de mémoire,
puisque certaines courses
vont donner des épreuves de mémoire.
Tout ça, c'est très chouette,
mais il ne faut pas oublier
les qualités mentales requises :
la solidarité,
l'humilité de demander de l'aide,
le fait d'avoir une analyse
à chaud sur les obstacles.
Quand on arrive à fond sur un obstacle,
on ne pense pas toujours
à la bonne solution.
Certains obstacles sont faits
pour être contournés.
Quand on voit des murs
trop hauts de troncs d'arbres,
les organisateurs eux-mêmes le disent :
« Mais pourquoi n'avez-vous
pas pris du recul
et pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas passés dessous
alors que ce n'était pas interdit ?
Pourquoi n'avez-vous pas pris quelques
secondes pour penser, pour réfléchir,
pour demander de l'aide ? »
Cette qualité-là est indispensable aussi.
Et nous devons, dans la vie
de tous les jours, être complets,
prendre le temps de réfléchir
pour pouvoir aller plus vite,
prendre le temps d'être ensemble
pour pouvoir aller plus loin.
Et tout cela dans le but de se dépasser,
de prendre confiance en soi,
et d'aller de l'avant avec envie.
Avec toutes ces dimensions-là,
quand la ligne d'arrivée arrive,
on se sent nécessairement plus vivant.
On a passé des obstacles, des difficultés.
Certes, on est couvert de boue,
on a quelquefois quelques égratignures,
mais, on est plus vivant.
Dans la vie de tous les jours,
nous avons des obstacles.
Nous avons ce besoin d'obstacles.
L'obstacle le plus simple,
celui que vous allez rencontrer,
il est à la sortie de l'ISTEC.
Quand vous allez sortir de cette salle,
ou aussi pour vous qui êtes
chez vous en streaming,
vous allez avoir un simple
point de vue à changer.
Lorsque vous voyez des escaliers,
juste après cette conférence,
passez-les comme si c'était un obstacle,
en allant de l'avant, et en vous disant :
« Je peux le faire. »
Certes, ce sera dur.
Certes, cela va vous demander un effort,
mais, vous vous sentirez plus vivant.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)